all right i i want to talk about another
one of these horrible incidents and
listen every time we have one of these
anti-mask incidents of assault and
that's really what it is
uh i
talk about
mental illness clearly seems to be a
component with these people the woman in
this video uh which some are calling an
anti-mask karen i really am not big on
karen because it's clearly a racially
loaded term it's really applied to white
women so i stay away from it i i call
this person a really bad person who also
may be mentally ill this is another one
of these incidents where a woman in
nebraska
some kind of covet denier some kind of
anti-massacre
is repeatedly coughing coughing coughing
on the person who is filming and we're
going to look at this and then we're
going to talk about what crimes may have
been committed here so let's start with
the story this was posted to the lincoln
nebraska subreddit um a few days ago
and the person who posted it you a user
named jessabird on
on reddit
says so my kid and i were at the store
tonight to pick up a few groceries when
this lady approached us and said
politely excuse me and to be honest i
thought she was going to ask me for help
or ask me where something was i was
about to say i don't work here lady when
she asked me why we were wearing masks
that's when i realized she wasn't
wearing one i started walking away while
replying because of the delta variant
and also because there's a mandate
then she went on about how she was born
and raised here in nebraska and it's too
bad some nebraskans have turned into
sheep she asked if i've had a vaccine
and said that my kid and i don't need to
wear masks because we look young and
healthy there were several other people
around wearing masks but for some reason
she chose to pick on me and my kid at
the end of the video some poor guy
working there tries to intervene and
basically told us all just go our
separate ways karen walked away and i
told the guy what happened he said it
wasn't the first time he's had to deal
with people like her at work i tried to
continue my shopping but the lady
followed me around the store i told her
she needs to keep her distance and her
coughing on me was assault she kept
laughing and saying look at you it's so
cute how scared you are by this time i
was absolutely livid trying my best to
hold it together in front of my kid i
didn't finish my shopping i instead went
to the self checkout to pay for my stuff
she followed me to use the checkout
right next to me i informed the employee
manning the checkouts this woman
assaulted me by coughing deliberately
but i didn't wait around to see what the
employee would say um so let's take a
look at this video this this is
horrifying um and what's horrifying
about it is
it it's less about the specific risk of
contagion um but it's that there are
people in our country
who
would do this and who think that they
are making some kind of prescient point
by doing this all right let's take a
look let's take a listen
excuse me
i'm coming through
so this is a disgusting person
but is she also mentally ill i don't
know i don't know i mean you know normal
people don't behave this way but even
that term normal has become very loaded
in coveted times
she's coughing on me
she's coughing at me
[Music]
because i don't need to have one on i'm
not sick and neither are you okay but
you have to be coughing you don't know
who is
by the way how annoying are those fake
coughs
[Laughter]
yeah and so
two years ago before anybody started
talking about coven you were okay with
daca going out not knowing you were sick
right
you don't know what to say about my
health
i don't yeah she's coughing on me i have
my allergies and she got all freaked out
where
okay
so
i think you get the point now there were
some people saying call the police next
time but one user on on the reddit post
about this said call the police this
time which i agree with
there's video evidence of of a crime
being committed okay what crime
we were looking into this and it seems
as though
in nebraska
this is assault in the third degree this
is nebraska of revised statute 28310
assault in the third degree a person
commits the offense of assault in the
third degree
if he intentionally knowingly or
recklessly causes bodily injury to
another person or
threatens another in a menacing manner
assault in the third degree shall be a
class one misdemeanor unless committed
in a fight or scuffle entered into by
mutual consent in which case it should
be a class ii misdemeanor so that's the
most likely thing
um the other idea that's been floated is
that uh coughing coronavirus coughing
attacks
might be able to be prosecuted as
terrorism
um
and this is an article from what is the
date this is from april of 2020 when
these coughing incidents started
where nikita malik a contributor to
forbes wrote that covid19 is considered
a biological agent
meaning that if you deliberately cough
on a policeman or merchandise which was
what was going on at the time
you could be charged with terrorism um i
think you know it's probably a stretch
to get a a conviction on that but at
least there's the idea that it could be
we do need to throw the book at these
people this is not you know when we talk
about
anti-social
behavior
detrimental to all of society where
culturally
um uh from a health standpoint from any
aspect you want to look at this
not taking seriously people who go out
and to make some kind of political point
i don't even know what it is or because
they're just out of their minds or a
combination of the two
are coughing during a pandemic on people
to scare them right uh it's got to be
taken as seriously as the law allows so
i am all for
if you if if you can do a terrorism
charge do it if this is assault in the
third degree under nebraska law
go with it but
the people have to call the police and i
understand that this woman wrote i just
wanted to get out of there i'm not
blaming her for that but let's all come
together and say that if we see this
stuff let's make every effort to
actually get police involved and really
make sure that these people even if they
don't get convicted have to spend months
dealing with the justice system because
of the disgusting thing that they did
we'll have more more on this particular
incident
um on the show instagram you can find us
on instagram
david pakman show find me on instagram
david.pakman we'll take a quick break
and be right back
i've struggled falling asleep at night
and realized part of it could be because
of the blue light coming from my phone
and computer screens and peer-reviewed
studies have shown that blue light can
suppress the hormone melatonin which can
make it difficult to fall asleep blue
light can disturb your circadian rhythms
but it hasn't been an issue for me since
i discovered blue blocks glasses which
filter out that blue light they're one
of our sponsors a lot of other companies
are mass producing supposed blue light
glasses and factories with no actual
quality standards blue blocks glasses
are made in actual optics labs at their
headquarters in australia they have over
40 stylish frames a prescription version
non-prescription even reading glasses
and for every pair of glasses that blue
blocks sells they give a pair of reading
glasses to someone in need you'll get 20
off when you go to blueblocks.compacman
the link is right underneath this video
and there's free shipping worldwide on
orders over a hundred and fifteen
dollars